e o tratamento da fibromialgia ele é
multifacetado envolve várias coisas você
tem que avaliar os sintomas melhorar a
qualidade de vida da pessoa entre os
medicamentos tem analgésicos
antidepressivos relaxantes musculares
medicamentos para dor neuropática você
pode fazer fisioterapia terapia
ocupacional exercícios regulares leves
especialmente alongamento coisas de
baixo Impacto e técnica de relaxamento
com meditação e yoga vamos falar um
pouquinho sobre as abordagens
integrativas da fibromialgia repos
hormonal quando dicado reequilíbrio da
tireoide aumento da energia mitocondrial
reposição de nutrientes que estejam em
déficit pesquisa de metais pesados de
outras toxinas ambientais e se for
necessário se identificado essas toxinas
aquela s ou remoção destas quando
necessário é muito importante mudança no
estilo de vida manter um horário regular
de sono evitar o estresse seguir uma
dieta equilibrada rica em nutrientes
evitar substâncias como cafeína e álcool
que pode podem piorar os sintomas